verschneite wälder weite hochebenen
durch den ganzen hochschwarzwald ziehen
sich bestens präparierte loipen tage
lang können skilangläufer unterwegs sein
in aller ruhe ganz mit sich und der
natur in einklang kommen
doch das elegante gleiten will gelernt
sein
vor dem laufen kommt im skilanglauf kurs
bei kerstin große bringt das fallen üben
man sich sehr weh tun gerade weil auf
die älteren eben entweder hüftprobleme
haben und für die jüngeren
es ist ein bisschen leichter zu fallen
man muss auch wieder aufstehen
heute sind alle teilnehmer anfänger wie
sarah hege sie fährt zwar schon länger
abfahrtsski aber steht jetzt zum ersten
mal auf langlaufskiern und auch mit den
längeren stöcken muss sie nun zurecht
kommen
im dritten schritt soll der erste
anstieg genommen werden das geht in die
oberschenkel
der schnee ist nass damit schwerer als
pulverschnee
da kommen ungeübte ganz schön ins
schwitzen
noch ein schritt am besten nicht
nachdenken stärker einfach mitnehmen
ohne nachzudenken
und wer auf das erste stück sind es gut
klappt dann könnt ihr sogar schon leicht
versuchen euch ein bisschen abzustoßen
den fußball ein bisschen nach oben
auf der panorama leute bei todtnau am
feldberg wird es flacher jetzt kann
jeder seinen rhythmus finden und es geht
etwas schneller voran
über 170 leuten in allen
schwierigkeitsstufen gibt es im
hochschwarzwald
sie verbinden sich zum größten
zusammenhängenden leuten netz europas
mit einer strecke von insgesamt 1200
kilometern
was besonderes eigentlich dass es hier
relativ flache leuten gibt die aber auch
für hochleistungssportler viel bieten
man kann aussuchen zwischen flach wie im
hinter taten wo man wirklich einfach nur
spazieren geht im grunde oder eben dort
wo es schon anstrengend das hoch geht
also da gibt es für jeden eigentlich die
leistung an leistungsanforderungen die
man haben will
das ist so das wichtigste und das ist
natürlich auch eine super schöne
landschaft also es sind nicht die
spitzenwerke der alpen sondern eher ein
bisschen rundere hügel und man hat aber
alpenblick
man fühlt sich frei man ist auch oben
und ich denke das macht den
hochschwarzwald aus im kurs wird jetzt
ohne stöcke geübt die skilehrerin macht
es vor
sieht doch ganz leicht aus die nur zwei
stunden haben alle die grundlagen im
skilanglauf gelernt
i